welcome back well the new virgins hotel
las vegas is set to open
this thursday very exciting time for las
vegas now you may
seem you may think that this area looks
familiar but that's because the
reinvented reimagined resort
is operating where the old hard rock
hotel used to be now get this virgin is
stripping away resort fees parking fees
but they will be offering free wi-fi i
know many of you guys will be very
excited about that
hector mejia got an opportunity to uh
tour the property and shares the
inspiration
behind the decor the theme here is
desert oasis and you can really see it
playing out anywhere you set your eyes
on from the main lobby
over into the lounge areas it's in the
natural colors
gems rocks and plants richard boz
bosworth is president
and ceo of jc hospitality and owner of
virgin hotels las vegas
we felt that the las vegas being within
the desert
and the journey to travel here should
greet you with this oasis in the desert
check out this decor in the shag room is
going to be really the
the heart and pulse of the sense of
arrival at the property
some design elements follow you up into
the 1500 rooms
suites like this one make up a third of
all rooms this means jobs for
1600 people for opening week once other
parts of the resort open
about 400 more jobs we are so proud and
so happy we have 1300 returning
employees from hard rock
that's about 85 percent of the employees
that stay to the end
former employees are also returning to
the casino floor
which will be operated by mohegan gaming
it's the first time a native american
tribe operates in las vegas
this is a huge renovation when we
remember that just
400 plus days ago this used to be the
hard rock hotel
in 2018 it was sold to virgin then after
25 years in las vegas it closed in
february of 2020.
construction is not entirely over though
the resort pool and day club
opened in may the day club ilya which is
a mykonos designed
two level day club which we think can be
very popular in the party environment in
las vegas will open up towards the end
of may hector mejia reporting
8 news now
well kirsten let me tell you we're also
told that the sportsbook will open
this summer pending regulatory approval
christian casa does 8 news now
all right we welcome them thanks
christian